c'est le premier jour de l'été et il n'y a
qu'une seule façon de célébrer ne manquez pas
le film le plus grand et le plus rose de l'
année il est temps d'enfiler vos
rollers fluo et d'obtenir vos billets maintenant
avec Bobby
où sommes-nous c'est la terre de Barbie  nous
allons devenir petits comme la taille d'une poupée ou est-ce que
Barbie est notre taille oui
fondamentalement tout ce que les hommes font dans votre
monde les femmes font dans le nôtre le président est
là je suis de rien Barbie est
médecin et avocate et c'est tellement
plus que ça ah  aidez-moi à l'arrêter salut
Barbie il y a aussi des stylos il y a
beaucoup de canettes allez au Ken's day je t'aime
aussi je ne sais pas Barbie 21 juillet
pondéré PG-13